(slow serene music)
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Hi, my name's Brenda Cantrell
and I'm the brand ambassador
at Unclaimed Baggage Center.
We kinda say you know, we're
an amusement park of shopping.
You just, it's a fun thing to do,
it's a fun place to come
and it's, we're a lot of
fun people to be around.
(upbeat music)
So Unclaimed Baggage Center
started almost 50 years ago
in a tiny town in Alabama.
And now it's a national
tourism destination.
And when people come in
they just truly never know
what they're gonna find.
(upbeat music)
You can tell the people that
have never been here before
when they just walk a
few steps into the store
and they just stop and
look around in amazement.
They're shocked at the
sheer size of our building.
It's over 40,000 square feet,
and we cover a city block.
But we stock about 5 to 7,000 unique items
to our sales floor everyday.
Some of the craziest
things that we have found
would of course top the list
is the live rattle snake.
Mummified falcons we've had in the past,
headdresses that are very old.
Things that belonged to
celebrities at one point.
Vacuum packed frogs in a suitcase.
Probably take the cake.
(frog croaks)
Another interesting thing
is the movie Labyrinth,
the character Hoggle,
is actually in our showcase.
There was only one made for that movie.
And there's a cult following for that
and we have Hoggle here in our showcase.
The found treasures are
really just a highlight
of your time here in the store.
(upbeat music)
- So this is just our
unclaimed baggage experience.
It's where a guest gets to
go through an unprocessed bag
only one person on staff
has seen the contents.
They've just taken out
anything harmful, embarrassing
or dangerous, but other than that,
it is strictly an unprocessed bag.
You're gonna choose to
trash it, give it away,
sell it or clean it.
And we clean about 50,000 items a month,
which is more than the average laundromat
does in an entire year.
- Wow.
- Wow, that's intense.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- [Woman] We sell pieces
that are $10,000 every week.
- [Customer] Wow.
- That's not uncommon for us
to sell something like that.
- Can I touch it?
- Yeah, you wanna put it on?
- $21,000 on my wrist right now.
Who would leave this in a suitcase?
That's crazy.
- The single most expensive item
that we've ever had on our sales floor
is a men's Presidential
latinum Rolex watch.
We had it appraised and
it was valued at $64,000
and a gentleman bought it for $32,000.
- But I'm like, can you imagine
not only being the person
that owns this, but the
person who like, forgot it?
It's just like, wow.
That's goals.
(upbeat music)
- [Man] Oh it is a ab doer.
- [Woman] Wait, so you're
supposed to sit like that on it?
(man laughs)
- I don't know.
(laughs)
That's probably part of the fun.
(upbeat saxophone music)
- [Woman] That's good.
- Cha ching!
(all laugh)
- [Woman] Nailed it.
(upbeat saxophone music)